>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE SOROS INTEGRITY
PROJECT PAID FIRMS TRIED TO
FUSION GPS AND CHRISTOPHER
STEELE 3.8-MILLION DOLLARS TO
DIG UP DIRT ON GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES.
DESPITE ALL WE UNCOVERED, JAMES
COMEY, CONTINUING TO REMAIN
DEFIANT.
INSISTING HE HAS NOTHING TO
HIDE.
TRIED TO REMIND HIM, YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO REMAIN QUIET.
YOU MAY WANT TO EXERCISE THAT
RIGHT AS YOU DIG A DEEPER HOLE
EVERY DAY.
LIKE, OH SIGNING OFF ON A FISA
WARRANT.
SAYING IT'S VERIFIED AND TELLING
TRUMP IT'S SALACIOUS BUT
UNVERIFIED MONTHS LATER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> INVESTIGATE WHAT?
WHAT WOULD BE THE CRIME YOU
WOULD BE INVESTIGATING?
IT'S A TERRIBLE CYCLE TO START.
CALLING FOR THE LOCKING UP
PEOPLE LIKE ME.
IT'S MORE OF THAT DANGEROUS
STEP.
I HOPE THE REPUBLICANS WOULD
STAND UP AND SAY WE DON'T DO
THAT.
ASK ME QUESTIONS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER THEM IN
THE DIDAYLIGHT.
LIKE TO SEE THAT TOO.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, THE PRESIDENT
SAID THERE WILL BE A CASCADE OF
INFORMATION.
DOUG COLLINS WITH MORE CLOSED
DOOR TESTIMONY.
VERY REVEALING.
WE WILL GET THE FISA
APPLICATIONS.
THE BULK OF INFORMATION CAME
FROM THE PHONEY HILLARY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
INTERESTING.
THEN GANG OF 8 INFORMATION.
WE WILL GET REAL INFORMATION.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT ASKING FOR
THAT TRANSPARENCY.
BUT WE WILL GET IT.
YOU MADE THAT PROMISE TO US.
>> MILLIONS OF AMERICANS BELIEVE
AT THE TOP LEVEL OF DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND THE FBI THEY
WANTED CLINTON TO WIN AND TRUMP
TO LOSE.
THEY MANIPULATED THE LAW TO LET
HER OFF AND TO GO AFTER TRUMP.
THAT'S THE BIG DEAL TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
REPUBLICANS AND SOME
INDEPENDENTS.
FORMER DIRECTOR COMEY WILL GET
TO TESTIFY IN THE LIGHT OF DAY.
I WILL ASK HIM ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
WAS IT THE CHIEF REASON YOU GOT
A WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE?
THE COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL TRUMP ABOUT
IT LIKE YOU TOLD FEINSTEIN?
HOW COULD YOU WRITE THAT DLINT
CLINTON DID NOTHING WRONG BEFORE
YOU INTERVIEWED HER?
MOST PEOPLE DON'T GET THAT
TREATMENT.
>> Sean: YOUR COMMITTEE WILL
TAKE OVER WHERE THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE LEFT OFF.
IT GIVES YOU A BIG LEG UP.
I DON'T KNOW AT WHAT POINT THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE REP LEASED.
-- RELEASED.
THE PRESIDENT IS SERIOUS SAYING
THIS IS COMING UP.
YOU RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT COMEY.
I WOULD ARGUE THERE IS A
VULNERABILITY FOR COMEY AND FOR
STRZOK AND PAGE AND McCABE.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS COMING THIS
WEEK FROM NUNES.
>> IT'S MY JOB:
DID THEY BREAK THE RULES TO GET
AN OUTCOME?
DID THEY MISLEAD THE FISA COURT?
DO WE NEED TO CHANGE THE RULES
ABOUT FISA COURTS?
THERE ARE ANY RULES ABOUT
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
OPERATIONS?
DOESN'T YOU TELL TRUMP?
YOU TOLD FEINSTEIN.
WAS IT A BACK DOOR ATTEMPT TO
GET AT HIS CAMPAIGN.
A PROSECUTOR AND NOT A
POLITICIAN NEEDS TO LOOK AT MB
McCABE AND COMEY AND ALL OF
THESE CHARACTERS TO SEE IF THEY
BROKE THE LAW.
I HOPE THEY WILL USE THE SAME
RESOURCES AS MUELLER HAD TO LOOK
AT TRUMP.
>> Sean: THE BORDER CRISIS.
HEARING FROM BARACK OBAMA'S
DIRECTOR OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND MARK EARLIER IN THE PROGRAM.
A REAL CRISIS.
DONALD TRUMP HIS VETO WAS NOT
OVERRIDDEN.
9 BILLION DOLLARS.
PRESIDENT TRIED TO WORK WITH
DEMOCRATS.
THE THINGS THEY WANTED.
THEY WOULD NOT SIT DOWN WITH
HIM.
A BIGGER VICTORY FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
MORE MONEY THAN HE EVER DREAMED
OF TO GET A GOOD CHUNK OF THIS
DONE AND COMPLETE.
I THINK THE OTHER COUNTRIES SEE
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GET TO THE
BORDER AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
KNOWING IT WON'T BE OPEN.
>> I ASKED THE HEAD OF THE
BORDER PATROL.
DO YOU NEED A WALL?
HE SAID ABSOLUTELY.
THE PRESIDENT STOOD FIRM.
HE SAID IF YOU DON'T CHANGE YOUR
LAWS, THE WALL WON'T WORK.
RIGHT NOW IF YOU STEP ONE FOOT
INTO THE UNITED STATES AND CLAIM
ASYLUM.
YOU ARE ENTITLED TO A HEARING.
WE HAVE NO PLACE TO RELEASE YOU.
IF YOU COME HERE WITH CHILDREN
YOU CAN ONLY BE HELD 20 DAYS AND
WE HAVE NO PLACE TO PUT YOU.
WE CAN'T DEPORT YOU BACK TO YOUR
COUNTRIES.
IF YOU DON'T CHANGE THAT, YOU
NEVER FIX THIS.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO